meanwhile martha um some pretty uh bad
news for people up in newcastle the
saudi-back consortium has pulled out
of this deal to buy newcastle united
yeah that's just happening in the last
few minutes we've learned that that
consortium which was led 85
led by the saudi public investment fund
who were bidding to take over newcastle
united
have withdrawn their offer and that
comes after this elongated process
it's 17 weeks now since contracts were
exchanged
between mike ashley who's the current
owner of newcastle united
and this consortium led by the saudi
arabian public investment fund
and they were subject to a fit and
proper person's test
which has gone on and on and there has
been no resolution to that
and there were claims that the saudis
had been complicit in piracy of premier
league matches
in saudi arabia there was also major
objection
and to this proposed takeover by human
rights groups
who pointed out that saudi arabia has a
reputation for human rights abuses
and there was also an intervention from
the widow of jamal khashoggi
who said that under no circumstances
should this saudi-led group be approved
to take over newcastle united she said
it would make the premier league
complicit in human rights abuses
in the country if they were to approve
that that deal
and so yeah just in the last few minutes
news that will be
enormously disappointing to newcastle
united fans
who had hoped that this saudi arabia-led
deal
could be a new dawn for a club and mike
ashley the current owner
not a very popular man up there on
timeside
and that will come as a huge
disappointment to them
but a relief to human rights campaigners